So, by now, we know two types of RAM machine.
The first one here on the left is the one that we introduced in the first unit
and it does not allow to use the if-better function.
So, this is something that is although as we discussed
it has some differences to your standard computer.
It is more or less close to your  normal computer.
And here on the right side, we have the RAM with the if-better function
and this of course is a much more powerful machine
so as you can see it is buzzing with computational power here
and this is totally unlike your standard computer because it has this guessing function about n
and of course, if somebody asked us to build this sort of RAM machine
at least I would turn them down immediately because it's not clear at all
how we should write such a function.
It seems far too powerful and at least to me frankly also a bit mysterious.
So, that's also basically the difference between the two machines
because here on the standard RAM, it's very clear what each of the functions that it has does.
Actually, if you know what the machine is currently doing then you can always predict
what it will do next because for every instruction it's very clear what it does
given certain variables or inputs and not so with the RAM that uses if-better function above.
Actually, most of the time unless this function is use, it's still clear what happens next
but every time this function here is called, we don't really know what's going to happen next.
It seems as if only this function here kind of knows.
Or if you put it in another way, if you go through an algorithm that is written on a standard RAM
then you can basically go through it step by step by step by hand
and say how its going to behave.
For this RAM over here, you could also go through it step, by step, by step
but once you encounter this if-better function here, you could not really say what its going to do next.
You would have to try different cases and so in order to better distinguish those two models,
there is a special terminology in theoretical computer science
called determinism and non-determinism.
And this standard RAM machine because we always know what's going to happen next
is called deterministic and surprise this one over here is called non-deterministic.
Now, it's very important that you familiarize yourself with those two terms
because we're going to use them a lot in this course,
and just to make you think about them a little  bit more, I would like to do a little quiz with you.
So, what I would like you to think about is,
if you're using the if-better function in a program and we run the same program code multiple times,
can we get different solutions if we're running it on the same input
or will we always get the same solution?
So if you think that non-determinism can produce different solutions on the same input
using the same code then please check yes, otherwise, check no.